what up guys welcome to the jess pearly
things youtube channel
today i'm going to be reacting to a clip
from better bachelor titled
never judge a book by its cover it could
be a dating
horror story this is true
um like very very true from what i've
experienced before i start
do not forget to like comment and
subscribe to the channel i'm
getting real close to 15 000 so each and
every one of you
like is very helpful to me okay
a voice for print i'm gonna keep
swapping i've had so many people love my
intro music the old way some like the
new way
i'm just gonna mix it up and keep it
different but whatever i put in the
beginning it'll be the different one at
the end
just to keep you guys happy should i
make intro music let me know in the
comments
um you know just yesterday i did a video
on the science
of bonding and pair bonding and why it
is different between guys and girls i
know it's a bit of a longer watch
but i think it's interesting and there's
some science behind why guys say hey
women cannot pair bond
if they've had a a kind of a crazy past
where men still can
put some time aside let me know in the
comments what do you guys think
is like a crazy past and like in terms
of pair bonding like
like i know what he's talking about what
do you guys think is
like too much for you and i think you'll
like that
and also let me know in the comments if
you met a girl that seemed like perfect
for you
super into you you're in love whatever
would you
like would that still be a deal breaker
for you
uh but i came across this story and this
is brand new as of today
and i thought i would share this with
you but you know jim jeffries once said
and i um this is not an exact quote but
it's one of his comedy skits he said
being a stud is hard you've gotta you've
gotta dress
nice you've gotta look nice you've gotta
be um you have to have some game you
have to make good money you have to have
a nice car
it's kind of hard to be a stud now in
reality really if you're just a really
good looking guy you can kind of be a
stud
but to be a [ __ ] to be an easy girl
uh all you have to do is be a girl
because as he put it there are fat ones
and
ugly ones and on and on and on all you
have to do is say yes
and some of you responded to my other
video this way with the with the old
parable
the key a key every lock is a master key
but a lock that is open by every key is
just a crappy
lock well i wanted to talk about the
mental health thing that many of us get
the warning bells when when it comes to
a woman with many past partners
and the this is a really good example of
not only
her proving it um but then talking about
it so let's look down through here the
bachelor runner up abby chatfield
so the bachelor is a tv show i guess
where one guy and they bring fourth i
don't know 20 i've never watched it
20 or 30 women and he goes on little
dates with all of them and
finally he narrows it down to one woman
and i guess they date or maybe get
married
i could care less about the show but
they bring on these bevy of women for
the bachelor and he slowly
and they kind of weed it out and then he
picks one so it says the bachelor runner
up
abby chatfield 24 so she's young 24
reveals she had sti in the past and
boasts about having
uh close relations with over 50 people
oh god 50. shocking
the bachelor's abby chatfield has shared
intimate details
about her intimate past appearing in the
latest episode of her
it's a lot podcast the 24 year old
bravely very brave revealed her
experiences
with stis when it came to self
shaming this is something that i still
struggle with a lot i've had stis in the
past she said okay so
if you're still self-shaming and not
good about yourself maybe don't go on
the bachelor and say
try to get married and try to die maybe
work through your issues before you drag
someone else in
to your messed up life
she goes on to say um she go let me see
if i can find it here uh she says abby
who has the word
feminist tattooed on her arm okay this
is what sorry
i'm not wanting to like i totally
understand why guys
like epic girls had too many bodies like
have an issue with it
but a lot of the guys that will like
judge women for like being a [ __ ] and i
think this is like where i can see the
girl's point of view
have never been in the position where
like guys are like
through like she's obviously stunning
right so she's probably had more guys
like throw themselves at her and like
than i'll ever have like in a lifetime
but like that's why it's not even
i think like i understand when a guy
says okay that's too much i don't want
to date you
but when you get into like the guys that
have to like
rub it in and throw analogies out there
like the keys
and it doesn't seem like the joker is
but i think that's where like
the feminists get like mad so to speak
shocking also boasted about the number
of people
she's fooled around with i used to have
a list of people
that i'd slept with when i stopped
counting it was like 50 boasted
abby she stopped counting at 50. oh
that's not good she's 24. stopped
counting
boasted do you hear all these so this is
again why guys go
i look man i don't want to catch
something
is this girl gonna say she's you know on
the pill or something and she's not
and i end up being like she ends up
being a mom to my kid and i have to deal
with her for the next 18 years
right and how do you protect yourselves
against this no matter what
you don't date that's why so many guys
are just like not dating now
uh she said the uh oh they go on to
explain what it is
uh and stis um they continue on
uh let me see let me see meanwhile abby
was left
heartbroken when matt agnew broke up
with her during the season finale
of the bachelor last year man did he
like matrix style dodge a bullet
speaking to punky in december abby
admitted she went on
a d spree shortly after she was dumped
okay again another thing that guys worry
about when you're so casual with your
past
why are you so casual because you don't
value yourself or
right you just say i'm just i'm free and
i'm
just love living life and women have to
realize that a lot of
older women give you extremely bad
advice
on this topic i remember being young and
having like
friends tell me to like you know because
i was i was a virgin until i was 19
which
in like like i was one of the last in my
friend group to lose their virginity and
i remember people like telling me to do
it i remember people to like
tell me to sleep around whatever and
it's just like interesting
like when there was a point where i
realized that like [ __ ] like people
don't want to be i don't even think this
is a conscious thing
but when people make bad decisions they
don't want to be alone and i noticed
this like
in myself like if i did like if i failed
to test
there's nothing worse than feeling like
you're the only person that failed that
test
but if like you'd ask your friend like
if you failed and your friend says i
failed too
like you don't feel as bad about it let
me
read these next sentences to you and you
tell me if this sounds like a
well-adjusted
normal person remember these are a lot
of the girls that are out there right
now
not all but a lot she said
um speaking with pumpkin in december
abby admitted she went on a d spree
shortly after she was dumped
sleeping with people who wouldn't know
her and adopting a fake
name to avoid spoiling the show's
ending while she's slated to appear on
the upcoming caesar of bachelor in
paradise
sources claimed she was booted from the
show
within the first few days because she
found out she was
probably kind of easy so imagine this
you get dumped on the bachelor and to
get
over it you you and but but you're not
allowed to give spoilers
because they record it all at once and
then it's released over a season so you
have to go several months without
letting everybody know
um what happened you have to keep that
to yourself and they have
they have people sign nda disclosure and
all this other stuff
so not only to get over her breakup
she changed her name so she wouldn't
spoil it
and then she just went out and went on a
d
spree just getting some and getting
something does this sound like a healthy
individual to you
if the answer is no ding ding ding
you're right
yeah and i mean i don't know anyone with
a body count over
50 i'm sure it exists but
it's it's hard like there's a lot of
girls that
get very like hurt by someone right
and they just try to fill that void with
you know anyone that'll make them feel
okay at the time
and it's not a healthy way to deal with
it and a lot of girls like cause
damage that
really like can't be undone and they
don't realize
at the time how much damage you know
they're really causing for their future
because there's a lot of media and stuff
out there telling you like you'll be
fine
but this is also the same woman that was
on here trying to get a bachelor
and failed by second place
she was the runner-up thank god this
dude did not get involved with her
what a hot mess she says um
oh and they go on about sti okay so
that's pretty much that's pretty much it
to the story
so let's let's look at this this is a
tick tock uh screenshot that someone on
reddit grabbed and posted up
when he asks how many bodies you have so
you accidentally subtract a couple
and divide it by four
oh god 30 minus a couple
28 divided by four just seven i actually
get like nervous
uh but tell it like because i i feel
like people will no matter what you say
even if you're not lying always think
you're lying
because of like stuff like this just
seven
and she looks to be like a college age
girl
you know it boils down to self-worth it
boils down to being a well-adjusted
normal person guys you know when a guy
wants to go out
and i cannot go to i cannot go to a bar
and just pull up to the bar and flirt
with a girl and say
wanna go back to my place nope i have
not proven myself
to anyone she doesn't know if i'm you
know if i'm in good
shape am i a good person am i a normal
person am i not dangerous
do i have a decent income um and i'm not
good looking enough to just walk up
hi there that's that's not me right
but a girl that is an average girl or
even slightly below
average can walk into a bar walk up to a
you know a guy having a couple of drinks
and says you know i'm really bored you
want to just go back to my place and
plow me girls usually don't do that
though like i haven't
like it's a very rare occasion when a
girl decides to do that a lot of guys
will will do the hmm do i want to use my
hand
or yeah yeah i'll go ahead sure why not
you know there's an old joke that uh
this reminds me of which is
fa uh what what's what's similar between
fat girls and mopeds
they're both fun to ride but you don't
want your friends no knowing you did it
or seeing you did it right
but you get the idea right is that guys
guys will drop their standards way down
just to get a little bit of action
it's called testosterone it's called a
couple of beers it'll happen
but a lot of girls are not aware
that like i think a lot of girls
think they're in a higher league than
they actually are because they're
getting attention
from more attractive this is what i've
noticed okay so if a girl's a six right
she could probably talk to a guy that's
an eight
nine seven eight nine right they'll all
give her attention
talk to her maybe not like treat her
super like well you know but she doesn't
really know any different because these
are all the guys she's talking to
so this girl starts to think like men
are trash around her chest because all
the guys that she's talking to
treat her like an option because she
seriously like she is then
um but they don't i think if more girls
realized
that 20 of the men get 80 of the girls
they wouldn't move like a lot
differently because a lot of girls don't
realize they're one of many
like they think they're one of like a
small
dating pool you know and like they have
a shot but they
absolutely have no shots so then you
have the 80 of men that get angry
because by the time these girls like
want them
and like realize their league they've
already been like ran through
or um they
like you know they've been like rejected
so many times and it's just like
frustrating but
what i realized the other day is these
men are angry because these are the
choices they have
and like they'll date them anyway like
they'll date the girl that's been
ran through or whatever because
otherwise they wouldn't be so
angry about it like a girl running
running out of options
because
like there's guys that i'm not
interested in that hit on me all the
time
i mean i have a boyfriend now but like
you know i
and i was never angry you're only angry
if you actually have to accept those
options or not get laid at all but women
don't women won't
and so again a guy to just get lucky
he has to kind of prove himself in many
different ways he does but a woman gets
to get lucky she just has to say yes so
when they're going out with so
many partners that it devalues
it devalues the woman it just does it it
tells a guy
look i really don't have any standards
just as long as he's good looking
and the fact that she got all the stis
means it was
unprotected unprotected
i mean at that point it just kind of
feels like
it feels like you're putting your d in
soup dna soup
and guys just aren't interested in that
do you guys feel like girls should
disclose to their partners how many
guys they've been with and if yes
when because it's not like you want
every single person that you date to
know that information right
it's gross it's gross to think about you
know it's bad
enough it's bad enough to know the the
partner count
but to know that that she got the gift
to keep on giving
multiple times which means that she was
with different guys multiple times
without protection
that is such a huge turn off and the
funny thing is to tell you how guys
think the funny thing is
knowing this even if every guy in a bar
knew this and she walked in and she said
hey
who would like a shot at me a good
portion of the men would be like
i'll just wear protection all right i'll
go yeah that's men
that's how men think a lot of men think
but it's not the same it's not the same
for women and so
now knowing this you know knowing that
she's basically the town
bicycle everybody will take a ride but
no one's gonna buy the bicycle no one's
gonna
that's not true i've seen a lot of hoes
get wifed up
and this is where i think a lot of dated
coaches get it wrong
they'll act like it's like over for
these girls okay that girl had a million
has been ran through whatever
obviously that's going to turn a lot of
guys off but you guys 80
of men aren't getting laid at all you
don't think
out of the 80 one of them
is gonna buy the bicycle like i don't
agree with that
like she's pretty hot like i hate to say
it
and and so in this scenario she's left
with
basically two choices a never having a
good guy a guy that would really care
about her
and value her marry her because
it's gross it's really gross or number
two
[Music]
she's gonna have to lie about her not
past
she put it on the internet and then the
guy's getting
involved with with something that he he
doesn't know the truth of the situation
so he's marrying a lie
or he's dating a lie
and this happens wait i mean this is you
know this young lady that i put that
screenshot up
of she's what 18 20 22 24
and they know this but guys do are not
interested in this type
of a woman some every guy not every guy
but
many men will take their turn they'll
have their fun
but they're not going to commit to
somebody like this because of all the
damage
because of all the i don't value myself
the the
to get over a problem that i have or to
fix my low self-esteem
i'm gonna make myself feel better by
changing my name and going out and
sleeping with a bunch of dudes
and this is what girls don't understand
it's like you make that decision
to do that and it doesn't seem like you
know your friends don't really have
repercussions you don't think there's
gonna be a lot of repercussions
but it's gonna it damages you
and i don't think most girls realize
like how much it damages them until
a lot later that'll let me feel
but then the guys just act like it's
like over there's no hope for these
girls they can't change da da da
and that's not true either
a lot of these girls end up in
relationships i know
a good amount
did they lie about their body count
that's a question i don't know feel sexy
and important and worthy again
nobody wants that mess it's damaged
goods
guys are just not into it so you know
again
not all women are like this but women
you have to separate yourself
from this how do you do that
by having some self by having some self
pride by holding yourself to a higher
standard
that's what men want and and
that's just a hot mess it's just a hot
mess and
again you know somebody asked me in the
comments the other night they're like uh
you know do you date do you have a girl
and i'm like me no i've been a monk
since like 2018 since the very end of
2018
and it's not that i dislike women it's
not that i i don't want to date women
well i don't want to date women i'm busy
i i've got
so many other activities in my life that
i just can't be bothered
this guy reminds me of my dad my dad
this is
it's funny because on like kevin
samuel's show they'll be like oh all
rich guys cheat da da da da da da
my dad is like literally the richest
person i know and he
he reminds me of this guy because he's
just always like
doing stuff like that because think
about it
other than that 5 10 20 30 one hour of
fun
that you may get with her for every
every day
but eventually every other day and then
eventually every three or four days
that's a lot of hours of in between that
you need to fill
you know if you fool around or have
relations every
what three days after six months or a
year when things slow down
if you do that once every three days and
you're but but it's a long time it's an
hour
all right what's that one hour versus 72
hours of
talking getting to know them being
friends getting close to them
what kind of what kind of person is she
she's someone that has such
little value that she had to change her
name and go sleep with a bunch of
strangers to feel all right about
herself
that'll be a hard pass from me and
unfortunately many women are going down
this route
guys if you'd like to support my work
links below thank you for the that's
interesting that he's like a monk
um yeah i
definitely agree with some things that
he said i don't
i think a lot of girls are have to make
like
decisions young and when their brains
aren't fully developed and i
and they're also like given like a ton
of attention at a very young age and
men are very like like judgmental with
that at times but
i can also like understand why you you
wouldn't want to
bang a girl that's bang 50 guys i get it
but let me know in the comments what you
guys think
do not forget to like comment subscribe
to the
channel and i'll talk to you guys next
time